Bruno Darro est avec moi sur ce plateau
bonsoir Bruno ils vont débriefer ils
font déjà d'un débrief d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron et Ian stottenber sur
justement cette cette rébellion avorté
de Prigogine de ce week-end et il y a
une inquiétude en particulier de la part
de la Pologne sur justement le transfert
possible des forces de Wagner en
Biélorussie ils ont ils en parlent oui
voilà pour le moment c'est c'est certain
membre de l'OTAN notamment la Pologne
évidemment les pays baltes aussi qui ont
exprimé
leur inquiétude sur la possible
installation de la milice Wagner en
Biélorussie tout simplement parce que
ils ont quelques dizaines de kilomètres
en commun avec la Biélorussie et que le
fait que la milice Wagner soit installé
près de Minsk évidemment ça rapproche la
menace voilà de leur espace en quelque
sorte mais en même temps que ce soit la
Pologne ou la Lituanie par exemple ils
savent très bien qu'ils sont membres de
l'OTAN et que si jamais l'armée ou la
ministre Wagner venait à commettre une
exaction en territoire polonais par
exemple il y aura une réaction tout de
suite de l'OTAN en disant je pense que
c'est plus pour pour marquer le coup
pour dire attention on est bien
conscient de la menace et rester quelque
part concentré sur sur l'Ukraine même si
évidemment ça ça ne peut pas être dit
comme ça mais évidemment c'est le plutôt
le sentiment de de dire que voilà nous
sommes conscients que voilà la
municipale se rapproche et que pour nous
ça n'est pas bon signe après est-ce que
les discussions très manuel Macron yens
toltenberg porteront essentiellement
dessus sans doute en partie ils vont
sans doute évidemment parler de la
rébellion avortée de il y avait gagné
Prigogine et des éventuels conséquences
qu'on a encore du mal à déceler
honnêtement même si on s'appelle
monsieur soltenberg ou Emmanuel Macron
en terme d'impact sur les sur les
combats en Ukraine
il y a par contre une conséquence plus
tangible c'est que le président
zellenski lui en a remis une louche si
je puis dire et dans l'OTAN non sur la
fourniture d'armes en accéléré parce que
dit-il c'est le moment l'armée russe a
été vacille un peu là avec tous ces
événements donc c'est le moment voilà
donnez-moi vraiment ce que je demande
alors les avions notamment et et pour
pour que les forces ukrainiennes
puissent vraiment mener leur
contre-offensive alors vous c'est
l'Élysée sur le perron de l'Elysée on
attend donc Emmanuel Macron et Ian
soltenberg qui devrait faire une
allocution prendre la parole dans
quelques minutes alors ils vont aussi
parler évidemment
de ce qui agite l'OTAN en ce moment on
est à quelques jours maintenant d'un
sommet qui doit avoir lieu en Lituanie
les 11 et 12 juillet
le fait que certains pays alors
notamment la Pologne et les Pays-Bas
notamment la Lituanie pousse pour une
adhésion accélérée de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN
justement on va écouter le président
polonais Douda et également vous le dire
elle inscrit sur cette question Bruno
nous croyons vraiment et faisons tout ce
que nous pouvons pour que le sommet de
l'OTAN à Vilnius deviennent un sommet de
décision
afin qu'il renforce la sécurité dans
cette partie de l'Europe
nous croyons profondément que la
sécurité de l'Ukraine est notre sécurité
à tous ce sont nos intérêts communs que
le temps soit aussi dense que possible
ici
et que l'Ukraine devienne dans un avenir
proche membre de l'alliance
nous comprenons que tant que la guerre
est en cours nous ne pouvons pas devenir
un membre de l'OTAN cependant nous
devons être sûr qu'après la guerre nous
le deviendrons c'est le signal que nous
voulons obtenir qu’après la guerre
l'Ukraine deviendra membre de l'OTAN
après la guerre nous voulons devenir
membre de l'OTAN c'est très clair c'est
le discours de Zelinski depuis un moment
et Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs ne
s'oppose plus à cette entrée de
l'Ukraine diplomatie française sur ce
sujet précisément puisque on se souvient
que il y a une quinzaine d'années
c'était notamment la France et
l'Allemagne qui s'était opposé à une
possible
adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN justement
à l'époque pour ne pas mécontenter le
grand voisin russe donc là il y a eu une
évolution mais elle inscrit voyez il a
été très clair lui il pose très
clairement les termes du débat pour le
moment effectivement comme l'Ukraine est
en guerre de toute façon il y a pas
d'adhésion possible puisque un pays en
guerre ne peut pas adhérer à l'OTAN
parce que si l'OTAN si l'Ukraine adhéré
à l'OTAN maintenant comme il est en
guerre ça déclencherait l'article 5 ça
veut dire que tous les pays de l'OTAN
devraient voler ce cours de l'Ukraine
donc là on part dans un conflit d'une
autre dimension et
mais par contre voilà il dit dès que la
guerre en fait ce qu'il veut obtenir
lors du sommet de juillet de l'OTAN
c'est ça c'est un engagement très ferme
il l'a très bien résumé dès que la
guerre sera terminée quasiment de
manière automatique l'Ukraine devient
membre de l'OTAN en tant que récompense
si vous pouvez avoir quelque part porter
les couleurs finalement de l'Occident
contre la Russie impérialiste de
Vladimir Poutine donc volody Myers
zenenski aider par quelques-uns vous
avez vu le président polonais il y a
aussi donc les Pays-Bas
qui est cette engagement très ferme à
l'issue du sommet de Vilnius que
l'Ukraine adera à l'OTAN dès que la
guerre sera finie donc évidemment ça va
faire partie des discussions Queens
toltenberg le patron de l'OTAN a en ce
moment avec Emmanuel Macron et on va
voir un peu ce qu'ils en disent
vous restez avec nous un Bruno on les
attend tous les deux alors il y a aussi
il y a aussi un autre une autre question
dont il discute sans doute c'est
l'adhésion de la Suède
à l'OTAN il doit y avoir une réunion
entre les représentants turc et suédois
sous l'égide de l'Otan quelques jours
cinq six jours avant le sommet de l'OTAN
pour essayer de faire en sorte que la
Turquie lève son veto et accepte que la
Suède devienne le 32e membre de l'OTAN
il y a aussi la Hongrie qui pour le
moment n'a pas ratifié mais ça la
Hongrie ça devrait être fait vers le 6 7
juillet juste avant le sommet également
la Hongrie c'était vraiment posé
problème mais la Turquie on sait qu'il y
avait un problème parce que la Turquie
accusée la Suède de de d'héberger en
fait des terroristes Kurdes comme dit
Ankara bon il y a eu des efforts faits
par la Suède qui sont un peu
insuffisants sur l'ankara voilà on est
un peu là dessus puis alors en plus
aujourd'hui il y a visiblement
un manifestant dans une
occasion en Suède qui a brûlé quelque
part du Coran donc ça va encore un peu
compliqué les choses ça c'était déjà
produit au mois de janvier
mais voilà c'est aussi un des enjeux de
ce sommet c'est que véritablement il n'y
ait plus d'opposition à ce que la Suède
adhère à l'OTAN sommet donc de l'OTAN
les 11 et 12 juillet prochain à Vigneux
c'est on attend toujours donc le patron
de l'otanian Stoltenberg et Emmanuel
Macron qui devrait prendre donc la
parole dans quelques minutes pour rester
avec nous ils sont un peu en retard mais
vous restez avec nous Bruno puisqu'on va
débriefer ensemble cette conférence de
presse